there is chaos going on in the senate
in government around this infrastructure
bill earlier this week
we read some of the infrastructure bills
it was nuts there was things like
invasive plant species removal programs
what that means i don't know i read it
literally they were talking about fauna
and other types of
grass and plants and all that stuff had
no clue what to talk about i'm not a
botanist i'm not a scientist
couldn't understand it one of the
organizations that is receiving a
billion dollars
one of the politicians wife oversees the
program
i don't know what's going on there but
that's just the facts that we were
able to pull out of it another section
we still today on friday do not know
whether the government was authorizing
the government to buy marijuana or
weed or not we still can't figure it out
and so uh we think that the government
may be authorizing themselves to buy
weed to study
what it's like if you drive high
craziness in the bill why do i say all
that
because there is one section that is
getting tons and tons of attention
it revolves around bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies
and the idea my understanding is that
the politicians in this bipartisan bill
said
we're going to go and we're going to
spend a lot of money and we're going to
need a way to
fund that spending and so one of their
ideas was that they were going to
create a little bit more um kind of
severity
around the taxation for this industry
for bitcoin cryptocurrencies
now the way that they do that is of
course the way that all political
legislation gets done is they don't
explicitly say it
they just put a bunch of rules in place
and it's up for interpretation it's not
very clear
uh what exactly it's meant to do or what
it's not meant to do
and so when you have some opaqueness to
language
what happens is people begin to run with
those ideas and try to figure out does
this mean
that they're trying to accomplish a or b
c or d nobody knows and so people
immediately jump to the most extreme
situations where those rules could be
applied
usually in the defense of the
politicians the rules are not created
to be used that way but in the defense
of the critics
they could be applied in some way that
previously wasn't thought of
so this is why we have a democratic
process as people put forward
bills or legislation they are debated
they are discussed
there's made uh changes and then there
are votes the vote's gonna happen
tomorrow
now the problem with this specific bill
is that the bill is very very opaque
when it comes to some of the intricacies
around cryptocurrency
and so there was initial language not
acceptable
not good there's tons of people in
washington d.c everyone from
uh coin center uh to a number of lawyers
et cetera that are all working trying
their hardest
to get the language right some of it is
that there is an education
barrier we are talking about people who
do not know a lot about the industry
that's not
their fault they've got a million things
going on they are there trying to do
everything from
uh macro policy and monetary policy and
fiscal policy
all the way down to understand
cryptocurrencies trying to understand
taxation
all of these different things this is
not an easy job i wouldn't want to be in
the job of these politicians
with that said that is not an excuse as
to why we can allow legislation to be
created
that would be onerous on a specific
industry especially when
that industry specifically is likely to
lead to
job creation economic prosperity and
innovation and so what we are watching
is that there are
tons of people who are calling their
senators
calling politicians tweeting doing
everything they possibly can
to make their voices heard so that the
folks
who are putting together this
legislation no we
do not want to have this be
an impediment to progress and innovation
in the united states
that is not what this should be intended
to do and so the only ask that i have of
you
is that you can call your senator call
the senators
and tell them hey i am in your district
i
vote for you or your opponents i care
about this issue
i think that we should not have this be
onerous
and there is an amendment uh to the
existing language
uh that senator lummus and two other
senators have put together
that i think that uh if you call you
should say hey
that's the amendment we should go with
the one that actually isn't as owner is
let's go with that one
senator lummus uh and others have been
incredible proponents of bitcoin
uh and the entire industry they
understand the importance of innovation
they understand the
importance of doing this here in america
making sure that the value is created in
our country and is captured in our
country
that is what you can do today is you can
call your senator and you can go ahead
and have your voice hurt now if your
senator doesn't answer leave a message
if your senator doesn't call you back
which they won't
tweet at them do whatever you want make
sure that your voice is heard it's
important
now we have a quote from pat
toomey and pat toomey says
if we were not to adapt adopt this
amendment then we could be doing a lot
of damage we could have a very chilling
effect on the development of this
technology and that's what i am most
concerned about
correct we should not harm
the development of the technology or the
industry
america was built on innovation america
was built by being a competitor in the
free market
we cannot have a situation where one of
the most important industries today
there was from
zero to two trillion dollar market cap
created in this industry in a 10 12 year
period incredible
growth in this industry we cannot have
that happen elsewhere we have to be
not only a player on the global stage
but we have to be a leader
if we want to continue to have economic
prosperity in this country and so pat
toomey there's got it
we then saw jack dorsey come out and
tweet and say we support
senator toomey and ron wyden's effort to
amend the provision the infrastructure
bill's current tax reporting language
would put
unworkable requirements on bitcoin node
runners
developers and miners not good
right that is not what we think people
want to happen here
what we believe is that the politicians
are simply trying to make sure that
people follow the rules
that they report the taxes and that they
help to
spend or fund the spending that's
happening here now we can disagree with
all of that
at this point right now the most
important thing is make sure you go call
your senator
and you make your voice hurt i think i
think that politicians are just being
politicians right now yeah so
i think when you think about it that
crypto is uh just by the nature of it
and how it how it works
it's a threat to the banking system uh
kind of within any country
but that means it's also a threat to
government right and there's no real way
that governments can control it they can
ban it but we've seen that that
actually increases adoption in most
cases there's a few other things they
can do but it seems like this is one of
those things that they're going to use
as a tool in their tool kit
which is create regulation uh put bills
out there and make it just
harder right make it uh so people have
to
go over these speed bumps and and face
these uh challenges to actually do the
work that's needed to
create the infrastructure for the future
so i think when you think about it in
that case
that's really what they're trying to do
i'm not sure of the uh total impact but
we'll see
i think uh it's kind of a shame that
it's coming down to the vernacular
that's using a bill
especially when you consider uh the 28
billion dollars that they're
that they're saying is gonna get created
in taxes we went through the
infrastructure bill the other day
they'll blow through that in a few in
like one to two projects it seems right
so
uh it doesn't seem like it's um really
well thought out it seems more like it's
a speed bump and really just a challenge
put in front of uh
kind of the developers and everyone and
the miners by politicians
the other thing that's happening right
now that's pretty crazy is that there's
an
entire industry of technologists
innovators entrepreneurs business
executives etc they're getting a crash
course
in how washington dc works right this is
insanity
there is literally a bill that is
put forward and within hours
people just start throwing amendments in
and then there's a vote that occurs
and that vote ultimately determines what
becomes law what does it and could have
massive ramifications over time now they
got a lot of stuff to do so i'm not
saying that they have time to take a
year for every single thing
but i am saying that out of a 2 700 plus
page document that not a single one of
them read because
it's not possible they could have read
the whole thing we are literally
arguing over a couple of words
on a piece of paper in washington dc
that is being determined by people who
don't even work in the industry
who do not actually do this on a daily
basis
and so i understand there needs to be
checks and balances i understand it
needs to be scrutiny
there needs to be critiques there has to
we can't just allow industries to run
wild and do whatever they want i get it
i get it i get it
but there's got to be some sort of
collaboration here there's got to be an
understanding there's got to be a
closing of the education gap or else
we're going to end up in a really really
bad spot right john well they've already
done two dozen amendments they have a
dozen more to go look
you have to make adjustments as you see
fit um and i understand that with such a
large bill it's 2 700 pages
it's just clear that you're gonna have
to make amendments uh what i think is
interesting
i'm curious how much this will actually
block the innovation in the space so you
see guys like jack dorsey comment on
uh the unworkable requirements it puts
on node runners developers and miners
it's gonna be interesting to see like
what those actually are and how many
people are basically step away from
crypto because of these requirements and
these tax
um implementations but uh we'll we'll
see that in the near future i think
the us has always prided itself on uh
you know welcoming entrepreneurs and
welcoming people that are going to
create value for uh the economy and for
themselves and other people
and i think this is one of those things
that they're just putting up speed bumps
that uh incentivize people to go
elsewhere right so when you think of
miners and all these other people that
you want to come
to the united states and create value
and do work and stuff like that
you're putting speed bumps in front of
them that incentivizes them to go
somewhere else and do this with lower
taxes or lower
kind of friction of course look at ftx
ftx is probably the best example
there is an american citizen who
worked in america at an american
financial institution
and they decided they were going to
create a new business and they
ultimately moved
to asia they've created alameda research
then they created ftx
right then they've created other
technologies etc they've got
jobs they've created where they've
either brought people from the united
states
or they've hired people outside the
united states all that value creation
all that stuff that's happening offshore
that's not happening in the united
states yeah what's going to end up being
hundreds of billions probably of value
that would be one of the most valuable
technology companies in the private
market today in the united states that's
got to be the scariest thing 18 billion
valuation just on ftx not including
everything else people take away
jobs that should be here right move them
elsewhere strictly because of the
regulations that our own politicians are
putting into place
i mean absolutely nuts hey guys thanks
so much for watching that clip of the
best business show
make sure you like and subscribe to the
channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday
and then head to sofi.com so that you
can get an account we can get after it
you